[Music]
you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
good good good monday morning
or lunch time depending on where you're
at
this great country of ours
[Music]
we
are going to talk today to some special
guests
we have some great guests here on the
show today
we have rachel bittikoffer from strike
pack
she's going to come join us today um i
think i think we're going to talk a
little bit about the gifts that the
nazis running around the country are
giving democrats and how they can use
this to win the midterms in 2022.
this is they are at the [ __ ] front
door knocking here
this is not a [ __ ] drill this is not
a joke the former president united
states stood on stage and basically
called out that he's going if you elect
him if my people will elect me i'll
commit sedition
right there right in front of a [ __ ]
microphone he's ready to overturn
the government of the united states and
become dictator crown himself king he's
ready he's ready for it
and i don't know if you noticed all the
sheep he herded down in texas but all
the sheep
you know they they
they claim to be christian
but i think i think they missed a part
in the book about the golden calf and
and idols
i think they missed that [ __ ] part
they missed it there's a lot of good
video of these uh these these sheeple
down in texas that showed up for the the
nazi rally i'm excuse me the trump rally
so we're gonna get to that today we also
i there may be a chance
just a chance it's possible that there's
a chance
that the cheeto dust mobster
the former guy
the orange mussolini jesus may make an
appearance here on the show today i
don't know we may have him here after we
get done talking to rachel
the political strategist with strike
back you guys you guys have seen her we
were she was here last week we did an
interview with her you got to go over
and subscribe to the youtube channel
and just keep tuning in as we bring
rachel in because she gives us
everything that we need everything that
democrats need here
breaking down week by week by week by
week telling us how we can win
so let's let's not waste a lot of time
let's bring rachel in here hey rachel
how are you
ah i'm good tony i gotta tell you man
you've really set the bar with your
theme song for your oh really
you like you like the lead in huh i mean
how am i gonna copy that i'm gonna have
to send this off to some of my
my friends over in in the hw and be like
[ __ ] you gotta deliver me something
better
i can't have tony besting me on podcast
i mean it's so good dude it's so good
you mean the uh the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating morons yeah so
that actually that's a that's a good
story um that's how it all got started
as i did a tick tock and i said that in
a tick tock and everyone kind of grabbed
onto that and it's a good quote i don't
know if i came up with it or not but i
guess i coined the phrase so you know it
is what it is we got a lot of people
saying hi let's let's see if oh uh
caitlyn says hi rachel mj says hi rachel
yoda's saying hi you got some you got
some great fans here on our show i'm
almost kind of jealous robin says good
morning
so and we'd like to include all the
audience here on the show so i wanted to
cut real quick i usually go to
commercial and then bring you in but i
wanted to cut because i got i got a busy
day today we may have we just may have
the former guy come on the show today i
don't know it's possible he's in a
remote location you know he's getting
ready for his his uh government takeover
here did you did you watch some of the
clips
uh from the weekend
yeah sure did you know i mean yeah
i just i love though this is what i love
about it right
i mean i realize like people get upset
oh we shouldn't be talking about trump
or showing any more of his crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] we shouldn't dude if you get if
you're if you're ari melber and you can
get one of these schmucks the criminal
investigation to show up and talk about
their [ __ ] on live national tv with a
trained lawyer you know you do that [ __ ]
dude and you know it's the same with
trump we gotta show people they're crazy
they don't aren't gonna just magically
know it in fact like many of the people
who want in even in 2020 i know this
seems so hard to believe dude but it's
true many people went into that ballot
in 2020 that did cast ballots for trump
and did it on very superficial
information like things that are you
know they aren't paying attention to any
of this [ __ ] so if we don't slap it in
front of their face and force them to
[ __ ] watch they're not anymore
so do you think there are some voters
out there because you're looking in this
data right is there some voters out
there that voted for trump in 2016 and
2020 because that was all prior to
january 6. that was all prior to i want
to actually be a dictator type [ __ ] and
and kind of what we've seen this weekend
not only not only with him standing on
stage promising pardons which is
basically outright sedition um but also
his statement where he's like yes we
were trying to overthrow the government
of the united states like that was the
[ __ ] plan and we'll show that here
but do you think there are some voters
out there that voted for him they're
like nope too far this is
enough can't do this well that's a
really complex question let me tell you
this not in the way that you're thinking
and not right maybe the audience is
thinking and certainly not the way that
democratic consultants think right um
because here's the thing like what you
can really see in data that most of the
exodus when when
i mean
electing and nominating donald trump
as your party's nominee the republican
party's nominee that was the moment
where that party really splintered from
reality right right and so like um the
part of the realignment that was that
could be shaken loose kind of gets
shaken loose there and we really don't
see
a lot of of loss after the general
election period of november and 16. we
see some declines but most of the exodus
of these white college educated people
who could not hang with this version of
the republican party natural exodus has
already occurred my argument is there
are more voters like that they are
ignoring uncomfortable news because it
would hurt them to know it right hurt
their feelings in their eyes
and if we force them to look and we
force them to look at my version of
messaging which is not like nothing the
left has ever run right then we can
maybe shake some more realignment juice
the way that they have done with
non-college educated white voters and
now non-educated voters non-college
educated voters across the board and and
we we have to be running our own
sophisticated you know uh modernized
targeting and it really is just critical
this time for us to do that but yeah you
can't just go to a trump i mean this
idea that trump voters that voted for
him in 2020 and 2020 and 2016
are suddenly now this is the thing right
right [ __ ] dude okay
so what you're saying is and i think the
point that we need to get across here
and the reason why i asked the question
is this isn't over like this fight in
the 2022 midterms and because they
i noticed what i noticed was that trump
and the republicans want to make
the 2024 race already the race and it's
like what we're not even 2 20 22 yet
we're
you know [ __ ] 2024 let's let's secure
the senate and and the house because
they're knocking on our front door these
nazis are knocking on the front door
like literally they're in florida like
you know putting up signs saying let's
go brandon and [ __ ] um let me see if i
can pull some of this stuff up here
uh here's the uh statement um that
donald trump made and you know i'm not
gonna i i you can go [ __ ] read it and
you everyone should read this [ __ ]
statement and the reason why is because
the last lines he could have overturned
the election
like he's saying out loud we wanted to
[ __ ] commit a cheeto dust kangaroo
coup like he's not even hiding it
anymore and of course
um yeah as these criminal probes really
produce results um possibly uh of course
we can't count on that either but i said
tell me tell me you wanted to overthrow
the united states constitution by
telling me you wanted to overthrow the
united states constitution a lot of
people pissed off they're like oh quit
posting this and blah blah blah and i'm
like look
if i don't post his statements unless
he is [ __ ] admitting guilt and it
needs to be something that the american
people need to see and they need to
understand what he's saying like he is
saying here we tried to overthrow the
government and we would love to do it
again
no [ __ ] and here's the thing is what i
would say to people who don't like
to see um you know people platformed
right like these people are are like
committing like you know they're digging
legal holes every time they talk
and so there's you know there's actually
a functional strategic reason why we
want them to be
out talking in public as much as
possible and then in so far as like that
statement right i mean here's the thing
if you could get
some of these white college educated
voters that are still hanging onto like
their brand loyalty to the republican
party to to see [ __ ] like that i mean
that was written by a president like a
former president right it's you know
it's it's literally looney tunes right
and uh a lot of people just don't know
how they don't have a set they have a
sense like an imagistic sense of how bad
the republican party is getting but they
haven't had that clarified for them and
if they are
if we do that then we're at least asking
them to go into a referendum-style
election which is what a midterm is
making
you know a brand versus brand choice and
not brand versus this party says this on
policy right and we're gonna lose that
fight for sure
well and and i i
what i i guess what i want you to do is
tell us
how how do
not not the the establishment democrats
but people out there that are are
fighting for pro-democracy causes the
people knocking doors the people wanting
to see beto
win in texas right that's a governor's
race that's not a senate race that's not
that's not a a
house race for the united states
congress but it matters it [ __ ]
matters because that turnout is gonna be
what we need and people have to stay
pissed and they have to go [ __ ] vote
so tell us why it's so [ __ ] important
to to make sure we
we straddle these [ __ ] republicans
with this anchor of
you are full-on [ __ ] fascist
tell us why that's important and how we
do that not not like politicians but the
people out there talking about this
posting on twitter or talking in their
churches their communities what do you
say how do you how do you make sure that
people understand what is at the front
door i mean here i'll answer it this way
this is how we know like the extent of
of like the danger we're in and the odds
that we face and that is the generic
ballot which asks you know americans do
you want republicans or democrats to
control congress and as long as that
number is tied or republican advantaged
which it is right now then we know this
for sure we know that out there in
normal america and again if you're
listening to my voice if you watch
tony's show if you follow me on twitter
i mean even if you read the washington
[ __ ] post you're not a normal
american you're not an average american
anyway at least in terms of civic and um
news consumption so you know out there
obviously there's a disconnect because
people are saying hey i think it'd be
good to put the republicans in control
of congress
right because that's what that's what
the polls are showing right that's
that's that that's the the trajectory
here that's the trigger and then in
addition to that tony the other metric
is enthusiasm so when we look at
enthusiasm who's excited to vote
republicans have a 10 to 15 point
enthusiasm deficit or advantage over us
and that is the exact opposite of the
2018 midterm so i keep hearing analysts
say well in 2018 they they put pelosi on
everything and it didn't work out so
good for them i'm like yeah and watching
20 [ __ ] two it will look like the
most brilliant strategy in the world and
it's the same [ __ ] strategy it's just
the fundamentals that have changed right
right we really need to bring a
political science approach to our
election hearing because they're not
they're they're not going to come up
with like a totally different plan it's
always the same [ __ ] right oh yeah and
their [ __ ] is so good i mean like so
here's the thing
you know crt that is a nationalized lab
created wedge issue that's going to be
deployed everywhere in the country every
[ __ ] race that's a swing race from
the school right on the way up and it
was created in the think tank it was
recognized for its its ambiguity right
what does it mean it means whatever the
[ __ ] you want it to mean that's right
and it was it was strategically deployed
in virginia it's not like the younkin
campaign and their consultants came up
with this strategy this is a rnc driven
strategic approach they're running
school board [ __ ] right now they're
throwing millions of dollars into these
fake grassroots moms of liberty school
board [ __ ] right and they're going
around and they're they're talking in
these districts they're talking in these
districts that aren't even theirs like
they don't even live in these districts
it's that strategic outrage that we
talked about last year and what they're
doing tony is they're keeping those
embers burning for the fall for crt and
so this is [ __ ] we can all see coming
and we can plan and strategically
counteract is right argument right if we
can see it coming and so it then so when
i look at when people ask me today
rachel are we going to win congress i
say no absolutely not and we know that
we're a [ __ ] fact because you're
[ __ ] scared
and we have a 15 point enthusiasm gap
and so what i'm arguing for the
strategic approach i want to come in and
bring is
my strategy
despite all the micro elements of it at
the macro level is designed to deal with
those two indicators
right so
so
we we we um we implore that strategic
outrage but
they are giving us [ __ ] just gift
after gift after gift i want to show you
something here um that shannon watts um
post yes
and this is uh shannon says in case you
didn't hear there's a nazi rally in
orlando today this is in florida of
course the rise of authoritarian banned
books armed insurrectionist demagogues
and disinformation america in 20 2022
has a lot more in common with 1930s
germany than many are willing to admit
here's the picture
if you look here it says vax the jews oh
that's cute and then up here it has nazi
um you know i mean
watch it right that's what you got let's
go brandon with two swastikas right
exactly in the backs the jews [ __ ] on
twitter i can't believe nobody is
including that because holy crap right
and you know what i would do with this
[ __ ] is i would take it i would
mean it and i would slap republican
party platform on that [ __ ] and i would
[ __ ] send it out you know that's what
they would do to us so right i i i don't
think it's a bad idea so any of you meme
meme makers out there start posting this
[ __ ] everywhere everywhere political
cartoonist i mean we we have you know
propaganda is always a bad word right
like in in you know it's always a bad
word like really honestly they use
propaganda and misinformation in a way
that that totally [ __ ] brainwashes
people i mean i watched a video of a guy
with a cardboard cutout of [ __ ] trump
on a segway at his rally like he was
humping the guy or something i'm like
what in the actual hell is going on like
no one i have never seen a democrat
never seen a democrat worship a
cardboard cutout of joe biden have you i
don't i don't think that exists but they
do
and it's because they use propaganda in
a way and they use information in a way
to get inside these people's skulls and
we can use the same way we just don't
have to use misinformation and hate and
bigotry we can use the truth and it can
be the simple truth and the simple truth
is they
they're ready they're ready to have a
fascist state they're [ __ ] they've
been ready for a long time but they want
it so bad and they feel like it's so
close because a former president can
stand up on stage and say i want to
pardon all the insurrectionists that
help me do an uh cheeto desk kangaroo
talk about that because what gift what
kind of [ __ ] gift is that
in this 2022 midterm like like trump
should be staying quiet so that all the
republicans can run and take the house
but he's not he's not staying quiet he's
giving us all the ammunition we need it
is but you know at the end of the day in
the wrong maker's hands that creative is
not going to have the same power right
so it's like one [ __ ] thing to tell
middle america hey donald trump is on
stage talking about partying in
corrections and overturning the
government but unless you make a
connection to them and why that should
scare the [ __ ] out of them personally
for their own children for their own job
for their own you know um
political freedom then you're not going
to get the same value right so it's it
you know it's good that i want people to
copy that i want people to copy like yes
we we must make sure if we're gonna move
the generic ballot and the enthusiasm
gap we have two things we must
accomplish okay number one we gotta make
republicans as unpopular as we are right
now and we're in power and they're not
so we have to make them visible we're
the only [ __ ] ones that can do it
okay
and number two
right like so like that's i mean that's
a crucial thing if that's the generic
ballot we have to make them the news
story every day between now and election
day and then we'd see generic we could
see generic ballot move okay
and then number two is our enthusiasm
problem because here's the thing
all of this [ __ ] that's going on that's
actual tangible
you know first wave fascism is happening
and yet here in our party amongst
democrats and leaners
we are less concerned about the status
of democracy
than the people and the party that are
attacking democracy and that's because
in their propaganda system as tony just
pointed out
they have been told we're the ones that
stole an election they think that
they're living in a rogue state dude and
like that's mass psychosis it's
incredibly dangerous but it's also a
political reality that you can see in
data they are like frothing at the bit
for 2022
and right now we do not have a system in
place to answer that i'm working very
hard right our frothing is not the same
it's not the same frothing right no it's
15 point deficit all right
i mean yes at the end of the day tony
you're right the throttling is not the
same either right i mean we're seeing
people advocate openly now for political
violence right that michigan state
legislature which i don't know about
that i i i do have that let me go real
quick to you because i i want to play
the quick clip of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
what that
saying
people have been asking me about it
if i run and if i win
we will treat those people from january
6 fairly
we will treat them fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them parts okay that's enough of that
[ __ ] um so that that's
that's where he's saying hey i'm going
to commit sedition like radney [ __ ]
open like he's not even he's not hiding
it well let's read what you had to say
here maybe just maybe media could start
questioning republicans about their
continuous support of this lawless
madmen rather than rather than
normalizing it
you know that's another problem that we
have is the media i think is stuck in
this trump loop that's what i call it
they're so used to covering trump for
like five years they just can't pluck
their head out of their [ __ ] asses to
understand um what's going on here's ron
had this this is the video you're
talking about right
okay so let's listen to this because
it's like over a minute but it is
[ __ ] worth listening to because this
this is their plan they've got a backup
plan and they're getting people [ __ ]
geared up towards violence listen to
this
and [ __ ] 160 of them that were
republicans right we want 50 50. if you
see something you don't like happening
with the machine did you see something
going on
unplug it from the wall what the
for hunting [ __ ]
it's not there for self-defense
the second amendment is there the
founders put it there to protect all the
others so so here's here's the gear up
number one i'm not sure who these [ __ ]
are but the one [ __ ] says oh if
you see something you don't like just
walk up to the voting machine and unplug
it number one do not do that whether
you're democrat republican don't [ __ ]
try to [ __ ] with the voting machines
don't don't do that you you definitely
will be you definitely be charged with
something um don't do that if
but this is their plan their plan is to
create chaos don't you believe that
oh i absolutely believe that i mean i
know it's not a belief thing right i
mean right this is this is their plan to
not not only create chaos inside the
polling places um because that's because
that's like oh they're gonna steal it
like they were un can you i can already
see it rachel like they're like to be
clear this is a man that's that's either
a michigan state delegate or wants to be
a michigan delegate okay and probably
will be elected i mean people i mean
people need to understand like
it's so comforting to think oh well
there's just no way that somebody could
look at ron johnson and was in wisconsin
especially you know all this crazy [ __ ]
that he says that he's gonna be
competitive and the fact of the matter
is because the turnout is going to go
down
the republicans are going to oh it's not
just about up and down turnout right so
like a lot of people like oh down the
look democrats lose high turnout
elections yeah no i it's always been
about the coalition of that turnout
right right right dominated by
republicans and right-leaning
independents which today it's gonna be
based on that generic ballot and the
enthusiasm gap right we know that so
it's not about belief it's it's no right
and then um you know we we need to make
it clear like this these people are all
electable okay ron desantis is running
his donations on jailing [ __ ] dr bocce
dude right right well and he's his his
surgeon general is basically saying the
same [ __ ] the person who's in charge of
health in florida is saying the same
[ __ ] garbage and they're parroting it
all the way down and speaking of
parroting let's let's listen to what
this [ __ ] says about arming themselves
if i can get there we go and it
of
says
the ideal thing
is to do this
peacefully yeah the ideal thing
i love that where he's like we're
definitely gonna have to be violent and
we want you violent like you're just
saying it out loud you dumb [ __ ]
yeah yeah the spoiler alert or anything
but right we have to do this peacefully
let's all show up armed at the polls
right here we go watch
if we can't change the tide
if we can't change the tide like so if
democrats show up to vote in large
numbers to make sure that they elect
democratically the government that they
want we have to make sure we're willing
to stand in their way and shoot and kill
them like he's saying it out loud
i mean come on dude we all know what
that [ __ ] means we all and it's
fascist as [ __ ]
how how we can't use this and that you
know that that's that's enough of this
[ __ ] guy um but i mean how we how we
can't figure out hey we need to use this
we need to point this in a direction so
that we not only have that turnout but
we have the correct coalition to turn
out to get this vote where we need it
because i believe and i think you
believe the same thing if we can create
this strategic outrage we can stay
pissed we can get people to go [ __ ]
vote because democrats are only the only
party that's going to deliver us
democracy republicans obviously want to
destroy it and they want to cut it off
and cut it down like a [ __ ] fresh-cut
tree so if what we have to do though is
if we can create this coalition for that
turnout we not only can win the house
and the senate we can win some of these
state races we can win governorships we
can do all this
but we have to we have to focus on that
strategic outrage and they're giving us
all the little chicken nuggets that we
need to make this strategic outrage work
don't you think
yeah i mean we and you know what we
already know all of this [ __ ] works
because we can watch the other party do
it in action and they executed the best
version of it ever in history of crt
which is a
nationalized campaign but it's so
sophisticated that the reporters keep
calling it local right right that's how
good they're at they've been running
this the system i want to put in place
now for almost 20 years and it's very
very good now right it's not it's not
like the like the
weak [ __ ] like they started off their
weeks off [ __ ] in 2010 looked like the
mcauliffe campaign's [ __ ] this cycle
okay
so like you know that's why i said it's
simple but not simplistic and we can't
afford the evolution so let's skip the
evolution since it's already in my brain
and just get to the ass beaten right
let's let's put the [ __ ] let's well
or take the gloves off and let's [ __ ]
fight yeah because i i can tell you i
can deliver for us sophisticated
nationalized campaigns that look like
local politics do and then we can use it
to at least force in 22 which is a
midterm cycle against us because we're
the party in power at least force a
referendum conversation on the other
side because the 22 is naturally a
referendum on us and if we are the only
thing it's a referendum on we are going
to lose
right well and that that comes with the
consequences and i don't think people
understand what fascism brings like your
job that you have the nice little church
that you go to the schools that your
children go to all that stuff is not
going to exist if they have what they
want uh your nice little cushy american
lifestyle that all goes away that's
right all of it it's not
they get to decide
when they take over when they have a
fascist state it is not a situation
where oh we're gonna make it peachy and
keen and it's it'll be cool with the
fascists in charge no they will take
everything away from you all of it you
will not have the [ __ ] life that you
have now you will not get up to go to
the same job you will not go to the same
church you will your kids will not go to
the school that you know today it will
not that is what they want they want
this to be torn apart because
they see what's coming with democracy
and democracy is the enemy of fascism
and that's why they want to tear it down
they say [ __ ] you know people are like
oh don't post his statement and on the
other side they say we don't have a
democracy get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
we we know what you mean when you say
that we fascists don't want democracy
because democracy is our enemy and the
reason why it's their enemy is because
they really do want to tear apart our
country and they want to tell you what
the [ __ ] to do they want to tell your
family or you call them breakfast snarks
right and then and that the phrase you
use
yeah no i mean here's the thing
you know i think it's really important
to keep everything in context right so
like okay let's say republicans win
congress in 22. let's say in that wave
it's so large that they also flip the
governorships of michigan pennsylvania
wisconsin all of which are up this cycle
and suddenly you go into 24 instead of
having you know states that are
managing elections for the purpose of
democratic accountability instead manage
elections for partisan outcome
and you tell me you want to go into 24
with that right i don't
and the reason is is that you know it's
not like it's like oh hey republicans
like let's say they they win in 24
because they curtail the electorate down
all right it's not like they're gonna
announce the next day some kind of ban
on you know
democrats working in the civil service
right it's gonna be discreet and it's
gonna be slow but it will impact you
and your children and your children's
children and it will not be in a good
way or we have a um we have a lot of
problems in america we've always had a
lot of problems but in general actually
have been making good progress on some
of these things that's why they're
fighting back so
um you know intensely to the point where
they're willing to dismantle
real democracy and america will go on
and have elections right but if you're
if you're curtailing the electorate if
you're
choosing who's in the salad before the
votes are cast
guys that's not democracy right
like you're articulating the outcome
based on who can participate in the
election you know so well well i mean
their goal their goal is to choose their
voters i mean that that is their goal um
because if they don't choose their
voters and and we do pile them under
mountains and mountains of votes uh the
fascist state that they want will not
succeed i mean it just won't because
again the only pro-democracy party which
i i wish we were
you know a different maybe a different
setup of democracy where we had more
than two parties but we're not that's
not the reality you can you can yell and
scream about a third party all you want
and all this [ __ ]
but it's not a reality it is not we live
in a political reality where we have two
parties and the other political reality
that we have is only one
one of those [ __ ] is for
democracy anymore and really honestly i
i believe it's been about
i think it's been 20 or 30 years since
there's been one party that really has
been
um
very
uh pro-democracy and the other one has
you know thin veiled their fascism with
debts and deficits and all this [ __ ] you
know that's what the liz cheney thing is
they want that party back
um but there are some people in the
party steve bannon donald trump all the
fascists out there they definitely do
not want that kind of fascism they want
full-on 100 fascism out front i mean
that's why he's saying what he's saying
in his rallies that's why he's saying
what he's saying in the statements don't
you think i mean
yeah i mean i i think sometimes i have
to wake up in the morning and like look
at myself
actually is all this [ __ ] just that it's
so flagrant and so ignored
like it's it's actually quite
fascinating in terms of criminology
right okay so it turns out like
committing crimes in plain sight with a
propaganda network you know no problem
right well you're better off doing it
just flagrant i mean they're so flake i
mean they did the whole
everyone talks about january 6 and even
in the fall post-election monkeying
around in the electorate but they were
doing that [ __ ] six months before the
the republicans any time a republican
tells you well that it technically you
know there was still fraud because the
state
governors overrode the state
legislatures and blah blah blah blah
well the reason they had to do that is
because the gop would not let people
remote vote during a [ __ ] deadly
pandemic when there was no vaccine right
so it's not like like the governor's
overrode the state legislatures and
that's the beginning of the story right
you leave out the entire first chapter
of the context before the gop is like oh
deadly pandemic screw you you can't vote
in public because we want less people to
vote so we can win right and uh you know
we just have to make sure like it
because i think it is so plain sight
everyone assumes everyone sees it i
guarantee you walk around a grocery
store go go somewhere with your friends
and ask them about the eastman
they'll be like who they're going to
know
power plot you know they have no idea
about any of that [ __ ] and if we don't
make it an issue if we don't make it as
salient as deflategate which i was
talking about today where you know
saturation coverage and everyone's
talking about did the new england
patriots deflate their ball and here's
all the standard protocols for bull
handling [ __ ] we're all experts on balls
in the nfl right right we could be
experts on democratic collapse too if
the media was talking about it more
that's right well the other thing too on
the other side of the coin
their side their coalition they know all
of it yep
all of it well they know their equation
well correct i mean they know they know
their misinformation and lies we know
that just by the way that they've been
able to employ the the crt voodoo [ __ ]
and they did that [ __ ] on purpose tony
like so here they come out of january 6
and there was an initial recoil of some
of that coalition that you were talking
about the beginning of the interview so
there was some initial like okay that's
finally it the bridge too far i mean
bribing the ukrainian president i was
fine with i guess but not this right
and so there was like this initial dip
but then what the republicans did is
they deployed fox and right-wing media
to start normalizing january's january 6
and recasting it as a protest that was
never an inner insurrection remember all
the rewrite that the fox news people got
in trouble with because their private
texts revealed they knew damn well it
was an insurrection that trump was like
behind it right so you know when we
think about that like we need we really
need um people talking about what's
happening telling everyone about it
forcing them to look friends or my
friends too are like oh you know i i
didn't know any of this you know and
they're highly they vote every election
so we have to tell people if we want
them to know so so you're saying that
there's people out there that vote on
issues that they don't know about oh my
gosh that almost everybody votes on one
issue and that's party okay right and
even in that conversion pool of
independence for most of them 85
party is going to condition their vote
even if they don't admit it to
themselves through the process of the
campaign right
um and you know when we talk about
coalitional turnout in the republican
model what they figured out was how to
keep their coalition engaged between
presidential and midterms
so turnout might go up and down but
their turnout stays pretty constant in
fact has gone up over over years even
when they're in power and that is a
product of how they election year the
modeling that they're using the
messaging the strategy that we can
replicate and if we can do that guys we
actually can survive 22 so i don't want
to leave everybody saying it's hopeless
but i'd also i'm not a bullshitter so
i'm not going to sit here and tell you
when the data is clear the generic
ballot and the enthusiasm gap are the
two indicators that we need to watch and
we need to move and if we can't move
then we're gonna be in real trouble in
the fall no matter what biden's approval
rating is no matter what's going on in
the headlines so so before we go um
because it sounds like i'm gonna have
another guest coming here soon a really
big name is gonna come on the show here
um and you can stick around in the green
room to watch everyone um but
explain one more time that what you're
talking about the generic ballot what is
that in terms of what does that actually
[ __ ] mean what what are those things
because
you know i think this is one thing that
liberals do is they they pile data on
someone and it's like you don't really
don't need to do that you just need to
make it simple as possible so what does
that actually mean what does that look
like to you when you're looking at the
data but when everyone out there is
looking at it what do they need to see
what do they need to know about that
people can track the congressional
generic ballot on the 538 website very
easy by googling that
and it will show you uh two lines one's
for democrats and one's for republicans
and it is indicating in national survey
data
from people
which party do you want to control
congress in 22 and yeah republican or
democrat right right in 2018 really from
the moment 2017 got going with trump
democrats led that and led it
substantially and they must lead it
substantially because as everyone knows
their vote is more concentrated in urban
and suburban places so they have to over
perform the national generic ballot by
at least four or five points to be
competitive to hold on to congress
in my opinion
right so you can track that at 5 38. yes
and and and like the way that you would
move me so like
what where this what this what this
indicates to us right is the conversion
preference basically of that pure
independent and pure independence under
my research are i argue look they're
largely imagistic they're not
well-informed people okay they don't
even really care much about politics
they don't know a lot of what the the
when i talk about people who don't know
what's going on these people are
definitely in that they know about tom
brady football but now
only what the national narrative top
line conversation right is
so you have to make your conversation so
benghazi right
republicans made benghazi a household
name how did they do it they used
control of the committee process and
they kept having all of these news
cycles about benghazi and pounding it
and pounding it and like people would be
like oh this is so important right crt
same way right so you can't democrats
want to look at polling data there's
many ways we we misuse polling data we
do a whole episode on that but one of
the most important ways is we ask the
public what's important to you and then
we like craft our campaign strategy on
that and republicans say what's good for
us politically we'll make that salient
and we'll make the election occur on
those lines and that's what i'm arguing
it succinctly we need to do here in 22
well thank you rachel for joining us
come back anytime maybe maybe they'll
give us some more ammunition
to fight for democracy i'm sure they'll
pile it on this week
as they try to hopefully the media will
try to get people to explain these
politicians explain why they're still
standing behind the president who's
calling for a coup
and who's saying he tried to overturn
the election he's gonna pardon the
people who help him which he had the
opportunity and he didn't do it so it
kind of makes no sense to me i gotta say
i'm sorry i'm gonna sign off i am gonna
listen in the green room though because
i think you guys are going to want to
stay tuned yeah
very special that's right i i i think we
got maybe someone who can tell us about
the rally this weekend thanks rachel for
joining us we'll see you next time have
a good one we'll see you soon
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babel maga
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new maga skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
i always like when rachel stops by and
breaks breaks down
what is happening line by line and how
we can use this
to win
2022 with our pro democracy agenda
and make sure that we do not let the
fascists come in the back door we open
the front door and we confront them uh
we have we have a special guest waiting
here i think um i i believe i believe i
believe this guest is ready and it's
speaking of fascist um but and i'm sure
we'll get some commentary on what
happened at the nazi i mean excuse me
trump rally that we had this weekend uh
but we also i want you to stick around
after this interview that we have here
coming up because we have missy modell
she's a great musician she does great
satire and political parodies
on tic tac we have an interview with her
we play trivia so make sure you stick
around for that as well um but it looks
like it looks like um we have
i don't i don't know it looks like
someone who has um a very orange yammy
tent to him in the green room here so
let me pull him in uh is this is this
the former guys this the cheeto dust
mobster
uh i i believe you need to unmute your
mic there uh
the four
grandpa poopy pants are you there are
you there on mutual mic a mutual mike
yeah it's hard to figure out i i know i
know
uh um
come on
there oh
maybe maybe the grandpa is having uh
technical difficulties over there we i
think we have gabe in the in the uh room
did you see did you see we have um of
course of course your your bike's not on
either yeah
yeah these people with their minds i
think we both have the same tech people
running the show
i mean i'm listen i i apologize but also
i'm not surprised that would happen to
trump right well you know he he he
probably doesn't know how to run
i think here he is again always back i
think he's back
they don't even know how to use tech i
mean you know what i don't like to be on
the tommy lahren show anyway like who
hello oh yeah just i i i i'm here i'm
here uh grandpa
i thought it was tommy you know no no no
no no no
you're trying to i might have been
double booked no oh oh is that why your
mic was not was not you know what i
think maybe that was that was the case i
was connected to the other show but but
i'm here now and and that's and that's
so so where are you you look like you're
on some sort of uh tacky ass where are
you are you are you i'm in mar-a-lago
but i don't need you guys to see how it
looks right now melania had to fire the
cleaning lady because we deported her
oh you deported her why did you deport
her i mean i thought you were
hiring illegal immigrants but i mean
you're against everyone else but you're
for yourself having illegal immigrants
right
i can't really comment on that right now
but oh is that right is that right well
let's see if gabe has any questions for
you do you know do you know our producer
and co-host gabe you know he looks a
little familiar he looks like my son but
that's all i'll say about that my
favorite
[Laughter]
those are fighting words so so if that's
how you classify as a fight so former
guy former guy let me ask you you had a
rou you had a nazi uh rally this weekend
that you went to um and there was there
was a lot of uh [ __ ] going on at
your alley they really worship you out
there like you're some kind of god or
jesus or something i i call you mango
mango mussolini jesus um are you saying
jesus to these people
um you know well you know what i don't
like to talk about well i do religion is
between you and god so i mean if that's
the way they see me well then that's the
way they see me folks am i right
yeah you're uh you're right who's is
there someone else in the room that
you're talking to
i can't disclose that information oh
okay so so let's talk about your
comments that you made on stage because
you said that you wanted to pardon all
these uh these seditious criminals uh a
lot of them are charged with sedition's
conspiracy so you're wanting to pardon
are you wanting to pardon them so you
can save your own ass because it sounds
like you would love to run to save your
own ass it's not about me it's about the
american people and those people from
january 6 once i'm reinstated or if i
have to run again in 2024 i will
treat those january 6 people very fairly
very fairly you know what they're not
being treated very they're not being
treated very nicely by that unselect
committee it's more of a witch hunt if
you ask me
so it sounds like it sounds like um
you're trying to preempt that if maybe
you or someone else you know that you
know might have to go be a quote-unquote
political prisoner as you you called him
um it sounds like you're trying to make
sure that you're treated fairly when
you're actually when your asses in the
ring are here you know it's not about me
like i said
get it through your thick skull it's
about the american people and that's all
i really care about but is since we're
talking about it since you're talking
about me you should buy my new book
trump poetry you can check it out it's
on amazon it's only 162
162 dollars wow
is it like a [ __ ] coloring book a
little self promotion oh yeah what about
the picture book that you uh that you
well that that's a that's back ordered
and you know that's that's a great
coffee table book melania helped me put
that together and we're just you know
we're very proud of it oh i i'm i'm sure
i'm sure you're proud of the coloring
book that you're releasing that's all i
don't know it's a picture book oh is it
like is it also is it like a pop-up
picture book too yes exactly oh right
yeah the coloring box comes out next
month so there's so there's another grip
next month there's the grip this month
the grip next month then so stay tuned
oh okay okay well so i i also want to
ask you and i know gabe is probably
interested in this dude the statement
that you released i think it was
yesterday how you uh blatantly said that
you tried to overturn the government of
the united states how do you respond to
making you know you you said it out loud
yeah you said the quiet part of that guy
what's going on well i mean it's it's
not very quiet because mike pence he had
the absolute right to overturn the
election and i mean i've said that
plenty of times it's now just written
down on paper so i don't really see you
liberals gaining anything here you know
what i mean you know the senate is
trying to
change the rules the democrats and the
rhino republicans specifically wacky
susan collins we all don't like her you
know if they're trying to pass
legislation
that will allow the vice president that
won't allow the vice president to change
the election that means mike pence could
have done it that's all i was just
pointing out the facts the real news
unlike you the fake news i'm gonna say
this though i i do have to i this might
be the only time i ever agree with trump
i also don't like wacky susan collins
[ __ ] her yeah well you know what we can
we can agree on that i think that's i
think that's we can all right we can all
agree on that uh who are you talking to
yeah
are you talking to someone there at
mar-a-lago is there someone there you
know i we we can't really we can't
really go in oh oh okay okay well i i do
have one thing i want to say about what
you um what you just said is that the
vice president united states has the
possibility to overturn
the the uh election so what does that
does that mean in 2024 even if you would
win that kamala harris can just make
sure that joe biden's device are the
president united states that's what i'm
hearing and i mean so i mean really
honestly what what the [ __ ] is the point
of running and what the [ __ ] is well you
know what sony camera phony camera let
me tell you a little bit about her we're
all you know she could change the
election and we had to make sure that
doesn't happen because we're going to
take them out we're going to destroy a
pardon anyone i'll pardon anyone but you
know what the real problem is everyone
here is talking about ukraine and you
know what i support ukraine fully i
support ukraine oh i mean uh i support
ukraine i really do oh that was a
russian flag that was already this is
the ukrainian flag i don't know what you
mean
you know the border crisis that's going
on in ukraine is nothing compared to
what's going on in mexico down on our
southern border i built a wall i built a
beautiful wall and so so that's creepy
excuse me excuse me i'm talking sleepy
no sleepy joe has done nothing
nothing nothing
okay so so back to russia and ukraine
because it does seem like you are a
little your boyfriend putin um is trying
to test is trying to test the president
because he didn't need to test you it
sounds like he had you in his back
pocket i mean you got his flag there
you're waving it around
what
putin your boyfriend yeah poutine
excuse i'm getting a phone call one
second hello
hello
no no vlad it's it's not a good time uh
i'll call you back oh no uh you know
he's not my friend so so is he listening
is he listening to the show right now
no no no he's not listening he doesn't
have me on a title is this is this
streaming to some russian tv station out
there now
uh i don't know you tell me you guys are
the fake news
you know crimes against ukraine
ukraine
yes
i i thought you were in bed with putin
you mean to say crimes against the
kremlin like what do you want uh you
know you take interpret it however you
like
oh well okay
i i appreciate you um you you you coming
we're gonna have to uh uh jump out here
because well you know
you know what i i it's time for me to
listen to my calming music anyway
and you know it was just it's been a
great time for
some
but you know it's just i have a very
busy schedule
mm-hmm yeah everybody
what the hell could possibly be on your
schedule we have to decide if i'm
running again in 2024 oh wait i'd like
to be reinstated as president even sir
because we need to stop the radical
liberal left sleepy joe and of course
phony camelot do you really want to live
in there america we need to make america
great again
again and again
and again when was it when was it not
great when was america not great the
specifics of your question will have to
go through uh other channels
so before you go uh
if you run or reinstate it because
clearly you don't really like pence that
much you know
um right well who's gonna be
who's gonna who's gonna be the vp who's
the runner no i don't you know it's
there's there's a lot of um a lot of
names going around you know of course
mike pence if he wants to be on the
ticket we'll put him on the ticket but
you know what maybe there's someone
better but you know ron desantis i
thought he was good i thought he was
good until he decided that he might want
to run for president so i got to take
him down i got to cut him off at the
knees if you get what i mean and if
anyone you know wants to i'll pause
harding okay i'll pardon them too
whatever
oh okay so so you're you're flashing
more pardons for more violence we get it
we get we we get the uh the fascist
tinger again we have to go um whether
you like it or not so
i have to go because i'm very busy so
you know what i
you know this has been fun and all but
next time don't pretend you're tommy
laron tony you know what this is just
really rude of you and and and i have no
time for this in the future
wow
wow there we go he just what it just
happened i was there no idea that was
that was something else yeah well you
know um i guess i guess when you book
an interview with the cheeto dust
monster that's what you get i i didn't
even know you know i i thought maybe i
could put this request and then this
request would come true i'm gonna oh i
hope we are able to get more politicians
or former politicians yeah on the show
you know i i mean yeah i was gonna say
knowing how narcissistic and egotistical
there i wouldn't be surprised if they
just wanted more screen time right right
i'm sure yeah i'm sure but what did you
think of this um
the former guy here the cheeto dust
mobster some of the things that he said
this weekend and
how he responded here
he's
he is slowly uh unraveling and revealing
his
his true core his true intentions right
uh i mean
like you you said you know you sent me i
saw the statement but you sent it to me
and i read it and i was like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i was like how do i you
mean you mean yesterday yeah yeah you
sent me this the the the release the
announcement or press release that trump
did and i was like i
don't i don't even think i can outdo
this yeah you even said you like can can
i make this even better i'm like no no
yeah i was like can i watch can i can i
nope not gonna work no i can't because
here's the thing he said it the only the
only correction that i joked about was
if i sent a follow-up press release and
i was like
uh i've been told that what i said was
not what i should have said so let me
just
uh follow up by saying hypothetically
if i were
[Laughter]
right
because this this is the craziest part
about what happened this weekend is not
only did he go on stage and outright say
we i want to to commit sedition but then
this [ __ ] [ __ ] says not only do i
want to commit morris edition but that
sedition that you saw that's exactly
what it was it was exactly that it was
exactly sedition all this stuff that
you're seeing these people being charged
with i'm gonna have to pardon them if
you want me to because that's the only
way they're gonna get out of this
because we did like he's literally
saying we committed sedition and they're
going to be charged and go to prison for
it and the only way out of it is if you
elect me so i can pardon him from the
[ __ ] crime of treason right that's
what he's saying it out loud like why
can't you people realize he's not just
talking about pardoning people who love
him that's not what he's saying what
he's saying is
we tried to overthrow the government in
the united states people are going to go
to federal prison because of it and
because of that the only way to get
these people out of it is to elect me so
i can party because no one else is going
to do that there's no one else out there
that is going to pardon these people
from the crime of trying to overturn the
conflict but i i i think about that and
i say
you know that also might backfire right
for the for the
for the subjects that he's targeting
which is like j6 all these people that
are you know uh potentially going to
prison or time or whatever that need to
get pardoned
you know at this point do those people
be like okay i'm i'm not gonna fight
this anymore or like rather i am going
to fight this
and then put themselves in a more
terrible situation so that they're
they're they don't even they're just
like oh i'm not guilty i'm not guilty i
didn't do it
and then they're like well here all the
crimes and you're not gonna try and do a
plea deal
you're [ __ ] right are they gonna hold
out with like
you know their hard-headed stubborn
behavior and then just ultimately get
[ __ ] over because they're believing
that a crazy man right is going to then
save them if he is reinstated or
reelected in 2024. in other words go to
prison for me now when when all the
supporters support me and put me in
power and i will pardon hundreds of you
which he had the chance to do this
already like he's right this isn't the
first time he promised to do this and i
think that's the thing here i think
that's i think that's the thing that not
only his supporters but the rest of the
country isn't seeing is a lot of these
january 6 defendants that are going to
go to prison for him because that's what
that's what's happening they're going to
go to prison for him and for crimes that
they committed in his name to make him
dictator um here's the thing is they're
probably pissed off that he didn't take
the chance to pardon him why yeah you
know so are you are they going to take
him seriously i you know i don't know i
guess that's the question i think that's
what you're trying to say is hey don't
tell on me don't rat on me because you
know just sit tight for a few years and
you know and then i'll go
right it's kind of like when you're in
like you like let's say you meet your
partner and they're like i'm not ready
yet just wait you know and you're like
how long am i waiting they're like i
don't know and then you're like it's all
in hopes
that you know they're gonna be like okay
i'm ready to now have this relationship
or or like if i had a business
opportunity they're gonna say
um
okay just give me like six to 12 months
as i set up shop and then i will
you know hire you or whatever it is
which is a super long [ __ ] time away
right especially to put just blind faith
into someone that has so far led you
astray and and and not helped you out i
mean literally trump had 14 days
or i guess 13 days to do whatever he
wanted do something for what he did he
did he pardoned all his [ __ ] puppets
right right yeah
his puppets that he needed to to make
sure to extend the propaganda because
that's what's happening is he's
extending this propaganda and he used
mike flynn roger stone you know all
these people to extend this propaganda
before we go to the interview with missy
which everyone should stick around
because it's a great interview it's
great trivia we had a great time with
missy modell um
so stick around for that interview it's
going to come up right after this but i
want to ask you about one more thing
because this is this is really
this is this is the dumb [ __ ] me and
rachel talked about it here a second ago
i'm gonna show you the statement here
here's the official statement from that
dumb [ __ ] and everyone's like don't post
this don't give him a platform i'm like
look i don't post his statements i don't
post his [ __ ] statements that are
absolute garbage and irrelevant because
he's irrelevant but he is he is
admitting right out loud what he did
january 6 and what their intentions were
that's why i posted it and if you don't
like it um follow me block me mute me
whatever there's all kinds of cool
things you can do on the twitter app to
make sure you don't see this statement
but we guys are not is what's going to
save our democracy we have we have to
know like the nazis down in orlando
florida you need to go look at those
[ __ ] banners that's their plan that's
what they want the let's go brandon is
now nazi [ __ ] it is and we need to tie
that let's go brandon stuff to nazis
everyone out there on twitter when
you're in your community say hey that
let's go brandon thing that's nazi
propaganda that's nazi propaganda it's
proof in florida here's a video here's a
picture we need to put it in front of
people like like rachel said make memes
anyone who's making memes out there
[ __ ] queue them up and start
spreading that [ __ ] around because we
have to we have to fight because they
want they want the people um
down in florida who showed up and i
think you posted a picture of these um
these names oh yeah did these ninja boot
nazis that i call it but they are
serious that's who they want in charge
but um now on this statement um
obviously he's wanting to overturn it
but then again underneath your crawl
when these people understand that
daylight is the best disinfectant it
gets in my [ __ ] i'm like people look
you just you can't not look away from
stuff that's super important and the
important part is they want a fascist
state and they're saying it out loud
they're saying it out loud you can't
ignore this [ __ ] the thing is like if
you ignore this stuff you know for all
the people who i you know and i agree
with you uh
i've had you know similar people have
come at me and they're like oh stop stop
sharing this stuff or even like when i
made the the the parody one right and it
went viral and people like stop sharing
and stop sharing it and it's like okay
one i'm making fun of this idiot but two
there are really important things that
are being said here right he is saying
the quiet part out loud in print on the
internet
right don't ignore it if you ignore it
then you're gonna then be that person
that says oh that's so crazy he wouldn't
do that he wouldn't say that like no
wait no way would donald trump get
elected in 2016 right right yeah yeah
it's that type of just you know
just you put the blinders on because
you're like
the because what it is is
people will write comments on videos i
make either the people on the side that
were support trump were like oh you're
obsessed with trump and i'm like you're
the [ __ ] that's trying to get them
reinstated or
shut the [ __ ] up but then there's the
other side which is on
the left where people are like oh stop
amplifying or platforming i'm like
listen one i'm a small account two he's
a big [ __ ] person in that party and
three he's not going anywhere he's
established himself as part of the
establishment now he is the republican
party going forward right you're not
with trump then you're against the
republican party is essentially what it
is right look at what happened to liz
cheney and adam kingsinger right the
only ones brave enough the only fascists
brave enough to pick up the shovel to
try to bury trumpism so they can get
their old you know thin veiled fascism
back they're old they get voted out
right the [ __ ] they get out of
leadership adam and king just can't even
run
this is what happens and the left is
like oh these are heroes and and it just
it you know they're ready they're ready
for a fascist state and if you don't
believe it go listen to what we just
watched rachel say and really go
subscribe to the youtube channel because
rachel's over there i i think it's like
the third this is the third time she's
been on the third time she's been on we
did we did an over an hour interview
with her last week we talked about
strategic outrage this week we talked
about this this fascism at the forefront
and and how we can use this as our
weapon like this is this is ammunition
that they're giving us to fight this the
fight of democracy like we can do this
we can use this the same way they use
the [ __ ] crt [ __ ] that voodoo we
can use this as a national [ __ ]
narrative and make it look local to have
strategic outrage because we have to
stay pissed we have to go [ __ ] vote
because really when it comes to
democracy
democrats are the only party that want
to deliver democracy republicans not
only want to destroy it but their plan
is to absolutely 100 percent destroy it
we've seen the video of the guy saying
unplug the voting machines and bring
your gun you pew pew i mean they want to
destroy democracy yeah and they want to
do it in a very very violent manner i'm
i'm i'm really excited about this
interview with missy um
not not to switch subjects so quickly
but we need to get to it but um stick
around because this interview she
actually you know we were talking about
trolls and stuff and people being
comments um she actually talks a little
bit about mental health on social media
talking about how uh it can affect you
you know it does have a wide effect when
people are in your comments saying these
things um you know taking breaks and
missy explains it really well and and of
course her her her parody uh songs are
[ __ ] just absolutely fantastic
if you're not following her over on tick
tock and instagram i know she posts some
stuff on twitter so go follow her on on
all those places but her her parody
songs are fantastic um john walsh uh who
may or may not have been trump in the
last little bit there um when i told him
that we were doing the interview he's
like the missy model i'm like yeah the
davis so he was super excited um and
john does great content himself so you
know that missy missy has it all lined
up so stick around
don't miss this don't miss this
interview we'll be right back with the
missy modell interview stay right here
after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv
slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show thanks for
joining us through the commercial we
have a special guest for you today
she is she is an internet internet
sensation wow she loves her her song
parodies uh on tick tock missy modell
how are you missy i appreciate you
joining us on the show thank you very
much for coming thank you what an
introduction it is yeah well you know i
i i get the worst introductions in the
world the worst i mean i don't know i
would say i forgot well well sometimes i
forget the guest's name so i mean this
is yeah okay
i i sometimes wish that tony would just
introduce me into like my work meetings
during the day he's like gabe sanchez
designer you know just learning
ding ding ding exactly
in the hawaiian shirt and the black cap
in corner a yeah you know i i try i try
missy how are you how are you i'm pretty
good i'm pretty i heard you had a big
move from one apartment to the other and
you're trying to get situated here huge
move i know people don't understand that
when you move up one floor in the same
building
luster but for me it was a lot it was
this whole move did you use the stairs
or was it an elevator type move there
was an elevator situation oh okay okay
couches i had a bed
there were like large pieces of
furniture that had to be transferred the
whole life had to be moved
but always a good opportunity to go
through things i found my head shots
from oh okay md2
that was portaling i can share it did
you keep them or did you toss them did
you do a mari condo what did you do
i'm going to give them away as gifts i'm
going to sign them yeah i'm going to
send you two in the mail to some of our
tours i'll put it up on the wall i'll
get a headshot like past headshot yeah
i'll have yeah if anyone wants to send
me headshots whoever's listening on when
the show is on uh just send it to me and
i'll put it on the wall yeah right here
yeah we'll we'll decorate gabe's studio
there yeah i'm sure i'm sure my
girlfriend would love that
just late at night there's a light
shimmering from the moon hits the eyes
and just meets you looks like a con it
looks like a comedy store hallway where
yeah exactly
or like a restaurant you're like oh this
famous person came in
gave him the thumbs up yeah
so funny yeah so that was a discovery
that was very very cool but i moved
about a month ago i have no desk yet or
like a place to sit aside from my couch
so things are in process very new aged
go without the desk just stand
everywhere and nomad in my home you know
there you go the floor is the desk right
you know the floor is the disc
you got to work what you got to work
with so tell us about tell us about your
how you got here because i was watching
your tic-tac videos today and i want to
talk about one in particular the tucker
carlson eminem you know eminem's have to
be sexy thing yeah this is getting
ridiculous because you do a lot of
parody and parody is me and gabe talk
about this a lot satire and parody is
almost dead and it's great because these
people just they they make it so
difficult to do parody of them because
they are parody of themselves but tell
us about like how you got to to where
you are now doing some of these videos
because they are fantastic with some of
the song parody and stuff that you do
thank you so much so i don't know if
people know that i was or i am but i was
a musician for about 10 years full-time
i was living in l.a i hadn't met gabe
yet unfortunately so we couldn't hang um
but i was a songwriter i sang on a carly
rae jepsen song i wrote for netflix and
for disney and nickelodeon and i had a
whole songwriting
but also trying to be a pop singer the
pop singer piece didn't exactly pop off
because i don't think it was like
authentic to me but i've always had this
also
really large interest in social justice
and community and
when trump got elected into that
whenever i literally have like blacked
it out i have no semblance of time oh we
all have
yeah i think we're gonna cut that part
out and just you know just cut it and
just split it twice it or or we just
have it just black screen and we just
hear us talking through it you know
right right right right
no so when trump got elected and at that
point i was doing music but almost like
moving away from it because for people
listening are aware of it the music
industry is so hard and as a woman it's
and
it's just a very challenging industry
so i was just getting disillusioned and
i'm like i'm just gonna do marketing and
that's what i want to do
because it's easier for now and then he
got elected and i had this need come
over me that i need to express myself
through song and i need and i was so
devastated that comedy and humor was the
only thing getting me through it so i
did a parody i don't think gabe you've
seen it uh or maybe i sent it how lovely
to be a woman
and it was
me as like a trump supporter loving
being a woman under his reign and it
went viral to my shock and awe and it
really resonated with people but still i
wasn't fully hooked and convinced that
this could be a viable path for me
because i'm like could it be that easy
that two things i love to do can work
really well together like talking about
it and singing and singing
so then um quarantine covet happens and
i'm forced to sit with myself and what i
want and what i want to create and how
again how do you get through
the darkest of times for me it's through
comedy so i made a song about andrew
cuomo
did not age very well every day yeah
well you know
it happens it happened
i'm gonna own it you know what i mean
i'm not gonna be when it didn't happen i
made a song a fan girl video about him
and it went extremely viral again
and that
was it for me and i started creating oh
like a large amount of content during
this time so over the past two years
i've kind of fell into this rhythm and
create around what's going on in the
news
even things around mental health and
more you know evergreen concepts
and and that's where i'm at today that's
why i noticed that you do a lot of
videos around women's issues as well
um you know especially with some of the
stuff going on um here lately
with these fascists trying to take away
women's liberty um you know and they're
trying to do it little by little in some
of these red states but ultimately their
goal is to
to take away women's liberty of their
bodies um it's it's really disappointing
that that they're oh my body my choice
with other things but when it comes
when it comes to the actual my body my
choice they don't but you actually use
that song and parody and comedy um you
say get yourself through but i think i
think because of the views and the likes
and all the comments that you have
you're helping other people get through
that as well so
um
tell us about though you you mentioned
before we came on air
that um you have taken a little bit of
hiatus
but you plan on getting back into it so
tell us a little bit about that
yeah so i think
as a lot of creators can probably
connect to there is a bit of burnout
that can happen you're and just trying
to catch that last video and you
sometimes could get so caught up in the
views they almost forget the reason why
you started when i create these videos
it's genuinely because i feel like i
have something i want to say and
hopefully other people can connect to it
but i i really try not to fixate on how
it resonates or like how many views
but i got into that place a little bit
and i got really trolled so despite
having a really good reaction from
people i've also had
a lot of horrible reactions to my videos
to the point where it was almost like
mentally destructive for me every time i
would open tik tok i would have
literally tens of thousands of comments
that are the most horrific things you
could possibly say
and i think it and i don't know if you
guys have like if that affects you too
i'm sure you've you know your candid
about your beliefs have you experienced
this kind of backlash and how do you
deal with it well i'll let gabe go first
because i know gabe gets more trolling
than i get and then i'll explain why i
think i actually don't receive as much
trolling but i mean like i've had death
threats on videos because of
i make fun of a real event that happened
right and like the style i do is like
here's a situation that we've all heard
about it's crazy insane [ __ ] bananas
what was happening behind the scenes
before like what led up to that right
and
um you know i'll connect some dots here
and there and i'll play with and have
fun
but some people don't like to see those
things and some people don't like to
like accept that's the reality of the
world that we live in and because of
that people will just be very just vile
about
the littlest things and i've come to a
point where i'm just like
i've had those moments where i've kind
of stepped away for a few days to be
like i can't do this but i've also
looked at and be like
i'm clearly uh
i'm hitting a nerve with certain people
right they wouldn't take offense to it
if it was not some way in some form true
to them right they wouldn't feel like
they had to
to push against it if there wasn't
something that they felt was real right
and for those people also i'm like i'm
not even gonna
i'm not even gonna give you the time of
day because for me i'm just like i just
learned to just let it
you can keep yelling into the void
because two things i'll do one
if you hit me on instagram i will
restrict you and you're doing something
and you're just going to talk into your
own silo no one else can see what you
said like say oh you don't block you
restrict no unless it's something really
bad i'll block but for the most part i
will restrict or i will uh mute that
person
so that if they're in my timeline or or
just in my comments then they're
basically just yelling to themselves in
their own actions better actually
yeah which again they
they're saying all this [ __ ] and they're
getting no
validation no response from anyone
and
for that i'm just like
boom you guys just you yell into this
void by yourselves and we'll call it a
day
and then there's other people who send
me messages and whatever and if it's you
know serious stuff i'll report it
but i've i've definitely dealt with that
sense of like people don't like to hear
those things so then they will you know
knee-jerk reaction is to attack you for
that whatever that statement was right
right um especially if they know it's
true but they don't want to accept it
and it goes against the cult mentality
or whatever the belief that they have so
my troll story is that i don't get
trolled that often and i think the
reason why i know the reason why because
i'm a white dude with a beard who sounds
like i sound and they don't they just
don't do it um
i i actually i believe that that is a
hundred percent true now i did have one
instance and i give them crickets so my
strategy is oh you can leave a thousand
comments if you want and i'll love them
i'll read every one of them but you will
get you will get no you will get no
[ __ ] response from me good luck
but i did i did have one time on tick
tock i posted a video about a
confederate flag that's in my hometown
area
and it really pisses me off because it's
this huge flag there's obvious reasons
why they have they have lights on it
they have a fence around they have
security cameras on the stupid flag and
so i did a video about it it got several
hundred thousand views and there was a
guy on there all day like nine hours he
was trolling every single comment like
he was on this video like i seriously
had to be on it all day like what are
you doing so finally because he was
saying it wasn't a confederate flag
because in the video it's hard to see
because it's a really cheap ass flag
like it's a just a printed flag so you
can't see the stars because of the sun
right so it looks like it just has bars
no stars
so
so uh i actually took pictures of it so
then i did a tick tock where i i i um
what does it call this stitch or comment
or whatever the hell it is and i and i
and i did a tick tock to his comment and
i showed the picture
and uh he went and deleted every single
comment
i'm serious and he commented probably at
least eight 900 times i was like wow you
spent more time it was it was fantastic
it felt good so that's the only time i
really responded to a troll but i
actually do believe i think the reason
why i don't get trolled is because i'm
i'm a white dude with a beard i sound
like i sound and i do the content that i
do i mean my phrase is [ __ ] them so it's
really i mean it's hard to
really and troll that so
but i mean but i mean you're saying
thousands of comments on one um video i
think a lot of people
deal with trolls but i don't think they
deal with trolls in in that and that and
that mo bash
volume right so tell me about like
because a lot of people don't understand
some content creators like when they
have you know
uh 10 000 views 100 000 views you get up
to 800 to a million views and you're
getting those trolls i mean it is
it's not just a few of them right it is
it is thousands of them so
yeah
and that that takes a toll on your
mental health and it sounds like you're
getting back to the point to where you
want to make the videos which is good we
we want more we want more song parody
but tell us
no so i think what happens is they have
these like organized coalitions of
people so they're maybe in like a
discord or someone some sort of like
group
and then they choose videos and they
just attack
so it's like a mob it's like a mob and
i'm i wish i was exaggerating like i can
i'll look later it was
there are like
multiple multi thousands of comments and
all of them are just so
a lot of white women actually or the
predominant one
for your content or just in general you
think
so the ones that had the most vitriol
were about dr fauci
about the vaccine
they're obsessed yeah it is so busy like
he's like a
kind older man
like literally a scientist
but they need an enemy they need to they
need somebody to
be the scapegoat right but
yeah i think if anybody like i think
that's why people don't read their
comments so i'm at a weird point where i
want to stay connected to my community
of people and that i love to talk to but
also like preserve my like sanity
so i'm trying to figure out what the
balance is but i think the key is for
people creating especially creating
content that's controversial if you have
a point of view
i wouldn't just don't read the comments
right yeah exactly crickets yeah i mean
i i read them i love them i'm like oh
you you love me you love to hate me so
much yeah that's that's kind
that's the other thing too is like the
amount of effort somebody will put in to
tell you how much this thing pisses them
off right
uh and i think i
when uh when missy and i
um
so we're actually well we're working on
a video right now breaking breaking news
yeah breaking news
uh it's for all those uh mask loving
people out there
um yeah i'm looking forward to this
video
um but
when
when we initially started talking there
was one thing that i mentioned to her i
was like oh i've definitely started
taking this approach where like i don't
really give a [ __ ] like the only
response i will end up giving people if
i do
is
uh i'll send the emoji
where it's the kiss like this like you
know like a swap with the heart
or i'll just tell them
you know thank you for engaging with the
video
you are thanks for pumping the algorithm
there right no really like you're you're
thank you for engaging with the video
and also getting like because all of
these videos are reals so the reels make
you money so the more engagement you get
the more views you get the more you're
paid i'm like you know whether it's on
tic tac or it's on instagram or whatever
i'm just like thank you so much for
right from getting paid more
and then they just they shut up they
don't talk again
the funny thing is one of the weirdest
things that's happened so i commented
something i thought was very chill on a
friend's video she posted a video of her
i don't even know how to explain it
basically like her husband like she
divorced her husband she had a panic
attack and asked the husband that she
asked a divorce for help
is that does that make sense
so in the video so it's like her
reenacting it so i wrote you're amazing
that wasn't okay for people i have got
like there are like hundreds of comments
on my comment like you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay
what is wrong with you
they think you were saying you're
amazing to the guy or like what
the husband's amazing what's wrong with
you
what
yeah the husband is amazing because she
divorced the husband and he's there
supporting her he is amazing but like i
didn't i was just supporting my friend
right
but also yeah it's like weird because
your friend is like listen i'm in a
position where i don't feel like this is
working out and i feel like instead of
making both of our lives miserable the
appropriate the adult thing to do mature
thing would be let's separate let's get
a divorce right and we can still be
friends correct so that went viral it
has millions of views i'll send it to
both and she's amazing she's an amazing
creator but
people i think the point is people are
so activated right now like they just
want to pounce on anything oh yeah
do you think too sometimes it's that mob
meant out where like they see like they
see 12 people commented on yours like oh
i got to go look at that and then in 12
more and then 12 more and then like 12
turns into 100 100 turns into 200 and
that's where it just kind of like piles
up because i i feel like that sometimes
like you go watch a video and you're
like this video really i mean
it this video didn't hit very well but
it's got a huge amount of comments or
it's got a lot of likes i'm like and
it's it seems like sometimes that's
that's the internet mentality like oh
well everyone's doing it so we have to
you know i have to go comment
mob mentality is a real thing you know
whether it's in real life or now you're
behind a screen in some sort of
anonymous state you're just like you
know i'll jump out now i'll attack that
person you don't know who the [ __ ] that
person is and everybody's an expert and
researched oh yeah
everyone is an armchair expert yeah
thank you
you're right i've noticed that like like
you know they were they were sports
experts one day and then when covet
happened they were epidemiologists and
yeah and you know and now they're like
they somehow got seven to ten years of
experience in a lab as a scientist right
within a month baby as soon as they have
indictments they're lawyers like they
are i mean they got like yale law
degrees in check
during it's like george floyd black
lives matter they were civil they were
like constitutional lawyer they knew
exactly they're like oh these are the
rights boom boom absolutely yeah every
time jury trial works
because what happens is it's just it's
like a dissemination of information from
the top up right you get the the people
who are
sending out the information whether it's
a political person or it's or a
politician or it's like a radio host or
whatever they drop it down and it's
basically you know propaganda like other
tactics and
they will just then spread information
or misinformation and those people will
then take those bullet points and then
regurgitate them and then it goes into
some facebook group or some ivermectin
community or whatever it is and then at
the end of the day like it's a game of
telephone with the thing that started
as maybe some aspect of truth has now
devolved into like
something that doesn't even exist you
know well you know i say a lot missy on
my show it's it's we're at the
intersection of wrestlemania and real
life like don't you feel like when
you're making your content sometimes
that's what it feels like like how did
we get in this so [ __ ] up timeline
that like i have to talk about this
stuff do you feel that way sometimes
yes i was just i don't even
guess
i just feel like sometimes
i don't even know what to say because
there's so much horrible stuff and when
you say it out loud you're like this is
actually happening right well for
instance i noticed you had a video about
uh sexy m m's right yeah and i can't i i
d i did i i talked about this for 20
minutes today on the podcast about
tucker carlson getting a boner whatever
he's doing
whatever the hell he's doing with these
m m's which i really realistically think
the way that he was doing it he he had
no clue about any of this they just were
like this is going to be a good story
for the cancer culture i think whatever
what the hell is that about
i feel like they know exactly what
they're doing i don't think they're
believing everything they're saying i
think they can identify what's like
exactly what you said tony like it's
gonna hit this is a story this is gonna
go viral because it's so controversial
and it's
they just do it because they're just
pumping to their audience and just
almost like
it's the way to just like spread fire or
something like they
i mean they're doing the same thing with
the mask in the in the vaccines you know
they do the same [ __ ] the same crazy
stuff like you're like what how can
anyone believe this and then you're like
holy [ __ ] they all believe it like it's
it's incredible how fast his audience
and it's all all it was is over a pair
of [ __ ] go-go boots
like that's what it is it's a cartoon
it's a [ __ ] cartoon yeah it's a
cartoon well what else but there were
some other like very bizarre
what was the other there was a recent
one
from fox news yeah some more over um oh
i mean we had potato head we had dr
potato head yeah potato head yeah it was
last year that was yeah they're like you
guys really cared that much about like
what are you guys trying to [ __ ] this
piece of plastic like what are you guys
doing you know right well it's also just
like trying to uphold this like archaic
view of women it's like if the woman is
if the female eminem or presumably
female eminem is now in sneakers she's
now androgynous and they are completely
not they can't recognize that they just
expect do you know
such an interesting thing so many people
commented on my appearance and like how
my boobs were small and how i needed to
get the video in the video that you made
all of my videos that's been like a
theme i think that conservatives have
this view that women should be blonde
hair big boobs like there's a very
specific vision
so maybe tucker carlson did not feel
like the eminem looks like that anymore
yeah i've seen there there have been
some funny memes that came out of that
whole segment where it was just like i
mean funny stuff that was just [ __ ]
on tucker carlson you know
uh i'm definitely one of them that's out
there i shared on him all day today yeah
he gave me he gave me 25 minutes worth
of content this afternoon so they're
just
funny like yeah i think they're like
remember laura ingram whatever her name
is she did laura ingraham she did the
you should you what do you know you it's
like yeah yeah you're so freaking
annoying i saw i haven't watched the
clip but there was a video of her um she
was re-enacting kate kate mckinnon's
yeah uh
you know
take on laura ingraham and i was like i
don't even know if i want to watch this
like this is going to be so cringe you
know it's it's bad it's bad i watched it
today i played it on the show today and
and i'll tell you when we play the
trivia game here because we're going to
play trivia missy we play always play
trivia with our interview guests so um i
think i think i'm going to be competing
with you which um gabe will be our uh
our host here yeah but i'll try to pull
up while we're doing that i'll try to
pull up the kate mckinnon video and
we'll we'll play that on the other side
so why don't we go ahead and why don't
we go ahead and start trivia here
[Music]
i'm gonna ask you five multiple choice
questions each question is worth one
point the first one to ring in on their
buzzer will get a chance to answer the
question get it wrong and your opponent
will have a shot at that point whoever
has the most points after five questions
wins
are you two ready what do i win you
don't win anything yeah you win you get
eternity hey look there's gabe's dog you
got your dogs there's gage now look my
dog is not here my dog sits in the chair
in front of me
he's waiting he's probably waiting for
dinner staring out the door
anyway yeah i know he can wait he's got
a couple hours question number one which
of the following broadway musicals does
not include music written by lin-manuel
miranda a bring it on b moulin rouge c
hamilton or d
in the heights
is it moulin rouge that is correct okay
you stacked this you realize that no no
it's not it's not all music stuff there
are okay stuff there's some movies there
are some shows there's an animal one
that's coming up right now okay what
home town did missy grow up
question number two which of the
following animals does not have quills
on its body a armadillo b hedgehog c
porcupine or d
whatever the hell that is here's the
thing i don't even know what that is but
that is wrong
okay well can you go through yeah yeah
all right a armadillo b hedgehog c
porcupine or d echidna armadillo correct
oh man oh my gosh he's smiling like an
ass you're kicking ass she's wicked
smart so so an armadillo because um i'm
i'm in missouri right and every once in
a while it gets hot enough to see
armadillos but we don't have them a lot
but like the only time you see them is
when they're like roadkill like that's
the only time we actually see armadillos
is
and it's so i never get to see an actual
armadillo like walking
it's always it's weird true story i've
never seen an armadillo in my life missy
i i don't believe so but i was just
thinking it wasn't the last one
porcupines and what was this other one i
i apologize for everyone listening it is
not a gemini it is echidna i know that
e-c-h-i dna echidna
uh yeah it looks like
oh is it really
he's got his own thing going on he's got
his own little uh yeah
he he's in he's in the uh
amorphous category yeah quill quill
covered monitorings is whether a lane uh
mammals egg laying mammals
laying mammals so like i like a platypus
right
uh yeah
there you go
you lay eggs okay
that's well fun fact about me yeah fun
fact about missy yeah well
we learned something all right so
question number three uh not animal or
song related which is the final book in
the harry potter series harry potter and
the chamber of secrets b harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone c harry potter
and the deathly hallows or d
harry potter and the order of the
phoenix i'd know nothing about harry
potter and honestly my son and my wife
would absolutely kill me if i do not get
this right because they love harry
potter they love the movies they love
boys they've read them several times
they watch the movies there's some kind
of like 20 is it like 20 years or some
crazy stuff that i don't know some kind
of anniversary just they just had a they
did just have a reunion yeah they just
said yeah 20 years from 20 years 20
years right so they watched like all the
things and they did the thing and then i
didn't i didn't because i'm not a harry
potter fan that is something that so d
though that's the one i'm going with the
harry potter and the order of the
phoenix mm-hmm that is incorrect i'm
sorry damn it all right well you go
through it again
is that everyone i thought it was i did
i was gonna say
it felt like a finale to me right right
exactly very like conclusive vibe harry
potter and the chamber of secrets harry
potter and the sorcerer's stone harry
potter and the deathly hallows and harry
potter and the order of the phoenix see
that is correct oh my god tony come on
man i tried to make this ridiculous i
made this trivia
man all right here we go
so did you read the harry potter books
no so you haven't i'm pretty good with
multiple choice i can't explain it but
she's like i basically aced the sats i
think i think like emailed this trivia
or something i'm getting i'm getting
stomped here but but gabe did you were
you a harry potter fan gabe yeah it was
actually i would say uh so we had a
reading
kind of part of my english class was
like you go to the library that we had
in our school you pick out a book and
then you had two weeks to read the book
and then take a quiz on it
and then basically if you read as many
books as possible within two weeks you
could take more exams which means
obviously you could help out the average
of what your score would be
for your grade
so harry potter was the ones that i was
like whipping through i started late but
i went through like four books and then
i took a test on four in one period
but they're addicting i mean they they
were addicting it when i read them you
know it's one of those books that uh
definitely engages you do you have
trouble separating the art from the
artist are you gonna ask me about jk
rowling right now yeah uh
i do appreciate it i can appreciate the
art
for what it is
you know
also hoping that the artist didn't
use the art to
transcend certain
beliefs and ideologies too much where it
became like propaganda i mean at the
point that i read it i didn't take it as
that and obviously the viewpoints that
she has right now are very unfortunate
and not
ones that i agree with but yes i can
appreciate for to an extent i can
separate and appreciate the art from the
artist we have we've had a lot of that
you know you got the meatloaf i just
died from ground virus yeah um um
eric clapton yeah
eric clapton is a
crazy kook
um you know we have uh with john
stockton you know the nba player a lot
of people who were idolized nba players
in the 1990s john stockton jesus they
had to cut his
um season tickets from guns out uh
gonzaga because he wouldn't wear a mask
he just wouldn't put a mask on they're
like yeah you have to everyone else has
to you have to he's like why john
stockton i'm not going to wear masks and
he's spewing a bunch of misinformation
like oh yeah that's enough you just
can't come here anymore yeah it's like
what is wrong with you you know maybe
it's a point where like
i don't know i i i hate to say that it's
the money but like they got enough money
they just they don't have to have the
the correct opinion or you know i i
don't know i i think it's it's gross
but at the same time they have to have
their opinion but it's sad i think what
you're saying missy is like
you had this person you're like oh i
adore the art and then you realize that
the person behind it
it's so true it's so i feel like that's
happened i'm like come on
yeah right it is it is one of those
things where it's like i hope that i can
appreciate it but it's like oh man you
are really [ __ ] terrible then it's
like yeah well you watch we watch some
films that have uh um harvey weinstein's
name on him and you're like oh i love
this movie but damn it damn you yeah i
mean it's like oh what did that person
have to do to get that role right that's
right
right right it's it's sad but it's you
gotta you gotta get to it i didn't mean
to bring you yeah really brought the
game down okay you're like i'm losing so
everyone's gonna lose that's right
that's right i'm gonna put out all these
people and show you
right yeah well yeah i'm trying to get
at least one question right here well
i i i prepared seven just in case tony
wouldn't get any yeah
let's keep going then all right fine
question number four
which of these tv shows doesn't take
place in new york city a modern family b
the mindy project see when they see us
or d friends doesn't take place in new
york city does not i've never heard of
the show when they see us is it modern
family that is correct
i was gonna say c because i didn't know
the other one i'm like i don't know i
watch
but when they see well i actually reckon
when they see us is really good no yeah
the modern family takes it in california
yeah yeah but when they see us is uh
it's a series a mini series that's about
the uh central park five oh and
it tells that story that would make
sense if we knew that we would've known
that that wasn't the one
but it's very good i definitely
recommend it to you guys and anyone
listening right now i highly recommend
by the way we don't get a paid
sponsorship for this yeah yeah i do i do
promotions he's always he's always
talking stuff pushing something from
someone yeah at some point somebody will
pay
i'm hoping somebody finds that clip and
they go oh look at this organic
promotion for this product maybe we'll
pay them for that organic promotion yeah
okay you know it's like apple wants to
give me something or whoever you know
eminem want to send us some sweat yeah
well
we weren't talking about how unsexy they
were yeah but there's exports they're
sexy
all right question number five which of
the following musicians is not a
canadian
a faith hill
b katie lange
c avril levine or d the weekend i i i
want to think faith hill is but i want
to say a because she isn't i don't i
mean that's what i'm that's correct hey
see i got one okay there we go
one on the board yeah
yeah so one out of how many uh well yeah
so it's four to one right now but here
here i'll give you i'll give you the
final two questions just okay let's yeah
let's do that
question number six how many syllables
are in a haiku a seven b b12 c17 or d21
21 oh i'm sorry that is incorrect okay
well b that is also incorrect the answer
is c
17.
oh okay i knew it had to be
you know that's actually a really good
question the follow-up question to that
one is how many lines are in a haiku
a three
b four c five or d six i think it has to
be b four all right incorrect five
incorrect as well i'm glad you guys you
know
we didn't like these last two questions
yeah [ __ ] these questions
i tried to go i went random on this to
be like where can we get this knowledge
uh the answer is three so
how many syllables are in a haiku
seventeen how many how many lines are in
a haiku three three
seventeen three makes up twenty three
well now i now now we know exactly but
you don't know what you don't know but
now we know
so we're like we're like poetry experts
now like exactly
i expect this show to now for the rest
of the episode to be only in haiku forms
that's well we could do that but i mean
we we got our education on the internet
poetry place so now we must be experts
there's probably a certificate that
facebook would give us yeah i can bring
you all one thank you thank you thank
you missy for kicking my butt in trivia
[Music]
so speaking because i i'd like to ask
you more about you know we kind of
brought the room down our tribute down
but i would like to expand on your
thoughts on when you see artists
um like their content's good
you know
but you know we have so many like you
can name them off like r kelly you know
you could just keep going and going and
going and going so
do you do you feed the beast or do you
because you know there's this big
boycott cancel culture whatever they
want to call it um you know what's your
feeling on it since you are a content
creator and more than that you deal in
the music industry i mean and some of
those some of the bad
bad actors and some of that you know
what's your feelings on some of that
like do you feed the beast do you not
feed the beast what do you think
i truly think it depends on the crimes
committed like how horrible is it what
reparations have they made for them like
are they guilty
like are they
working on themselves
because cancer culture's so weird like
if they've like murdered somebody like
that's not somebody i'd want to
listen to you know what i mean right so
it's not really you're canceling them
they kind of canceled themselves right
totally i i do think it's such a case by
case basis
i think right i don't know if i have
like a firm
thought on that well you know
one one memory that comes to my mind of
someone who like
you said rehabilitate um you know robert
downey jr had a really rough 1980s and
1990s and even early 2000s and
it took him it took him a long time to
get to a place to where he could be a
big superstar again and he really is um
i've watched
have you guys seen the david letterman
um
uh netflix series where it's
this person needs no introduction or
something like that yeah i've seen a
couple episodes and he did he did one
with robert downey jr and
i was very unaware that robert downey jr
is
a very strange like like in private like
when they're doing the interview like
he's not what you would imagine tony
stark is if that if that makes sense
like robert downey jr is not tony stark
but it probably comes from years of um
you know what you're saying like
rehabilitation but that's one career
in and of itself so you think that
someone can
find rehabilitation seek redemption
inside their art even i like to think so
because
i feel that way about prison reform you
know i think i believe in rehabilitation
there
so i would hope to extend the same
practice
but i think there needs to be work done
it's not like a month it needs to be
like years of like actively bettering
themselves right well we see the uh
louis c.k is back
um you know running around in circuits
and you know i i don't know what
rehabilitation was or not done there but
uh you know you see that that kind of
stuff
i i don't know i i think that this this
stuff though plays into the hands of
like tucker carlson talking about the m
m's thing and trying to make all this
stuff cancel because like you said is it
really can't cancel culture is it really
when they do these things
and they're almost canceling themselves
the only thing i'm gonna say on this is
uh
is
when somebody does something that you
know you're wrong in another group or an
individual or whatever you know that's
an action right and every action has a
consequence and i i think for a lot of
people
um they may believe that they are
free of consequences right and whether
it's jon stockton not wearing a mask to
go to a gonzaga game right there's like
a certain level of
i don't know like uh that they've
achieved right that they feel like they
in some ways are
uh you know immune or or invincible to
that whether it's like i did something
and like okay fine i'll pay some money
i'll do this
boom boom wash my hands free of that uh
but also there's people that are like
uh i did a thing and now all these
people are attacking me uh okay oh
you're canceling me oh you evil like
there was even there was even a guy this
past weekend who worked for merrill
lynch who was then fired yes yes he
threw uh they were uh he threw a uh a
coffee drink at this girl who was
working behind the counter did you see
this did you see this video yes so
apparently the story goes from the
attorneys after the fact that his son
had a peanut allergy whoever made the
drink had put peanuts in it he had an
allergic reaction he got really
frustrated and honestly he got
infuriated and angry and he assaulted
these people by throwing this drink at
them and taking it out on them not not
knowing who it was or which one it was
or anything like that
total total uh overreaction and he
committed some assault and crimes as far
as i'm concerned and they're whether
they charge you or not but it's kind of
crazy you know what you know the other
thing too about this this uh bad actors
and stuff it really is leaking over into
like the fox news you know we're talking
about tucker carlson earlier and we were
joking about the eminem thing but this
guy is they russian tv has been like
playing clips from fox news and tucker
carlson with all this ukraine stuff
going on um it has real world
consequences right like it's not just
you know our feelings and the woke mob
that all that nonsense but there's real
world ramifications for this stuff um
with the ukraine stuff with tucker
carlson and fox news and actually i have
i have the clip from speaking of fox
news i have the clip here from
uh let's see if we can pull it up here
um here is the the clip
from um uh laura ingraham or ingram
whichever when you say it now obviously
up here in the corner that is um the snl
skit that kate mckinnon did and we can
go watch that i've got it in the thread
too but that's not so important what's
important here is uh let's make this
bigger here i mean we can let's make
sure the ball is scared
let's let's it's it's it's ridiculous oh
it's well
you you don't judge janine on fox news
she lost her show she's going to the
five you know she's like she lost her
show she did well
how did i miss that because she's just
going to the fight she's not leaving fox
news she's just not doing your show and
going to the five but i think it's
because they don't want her to leave fox
news because they want to make sure to
have a good stockpile of box wine laying
around right exactly right so
yeah right but listen listen to her uh
give the parody of the parody of her
which is weird in of itself the reason i
like kate mckinnon and i have so much
respect for her as a talent
she's so even-handed in their political
commentary but seriously
think of all the low-hanging fruit
provided by joe biden and nancy pelosi
little pdb in the squad on a near daily
basis
i mean i think this is kind of comedy
gold don't you i mean really it is
fantastic comedy gold you just can't uh
yeah this is one of those moments when
the statement of like art mimics life
life
it's like it's just like it's just a
photocopy of a photocopy and you're like
i can't even like parody they really are
going to try to kill it aren't they
missy
i mean what do you guys think about
biden
being leaked down the mic
with him calling him when he leaned in
oh he [ __ ] leaned in he's like that
stupid son of a [ __ ] i mean it was
[ __ ] fantastic i think actually you
know um what it did was is
kind of reset this stuff a little bit
because
they they get on these tangents like
this let's go brandon stuff where they
want to say the word [ __ ] but they can't
and they want to go
do i do it right yeah well you know
that's that's right right i'm using the
joke how they did right i think that's
the way you should you should be so how
how do you process when you do your your
videos because i'm interested in that
like because i was watching several
and uh you take this topic and you you
make the lyrics um and sound like the
the song right it's a parody you know
and i i listened to weird al when i was
a kid but how but how do you how do you
but like what's your process like are
you like starting with lyrics do you
start with the topic how do you do that
if if it is okay to sell the secret here
yeah so it entirely depends sometimes
there's a song that i want to do and i'm
like what in the landscape of the world
fits into the song
um
and then
sometimes it's the topic
sounds like the song title so like i did
party in the usa and it was voting in
the usa which is like i just replaced
voting with party
but it has to feel like satirical the
lyrics have to lend themselves to
the conversation so i did um no mail
to no air by jordan sparks and it was
about how we can't get our mail and how
the joy is taking the joy out of voting
it was like so silly but like where can
i find those
moments in songs so it's like i have
this encyclopedia of songs in my mind
like so many songs so are you just like
walking around humming all day right
like not no no no
no no
yeah and i have like playlists on my
songs with different genres for
inspiration okay okay
so if there's like a topic and you're
like okay i want to do a parody of this
topic
do you search for the song first or you
just start figuring out what those what
the words are gonna be that's such a
great question
it usually is
i have some songs that i have already
like i want to do one of these in the
next month so then i'll usually like
play around
and see what's relevant or like with the
filibuster i haven't done this i don't
know if i'm going to but we gotta kill
the filibuster
like kelly parker yeah we're we're kind
of programming you know previewing here
yeah sure so it truly depends case by
case but i'm doing a new parody that's
man i feel like a woman you heard it
here first um
shania twain and that's i'm just calling
it man i feel like a woman and it's just
about
being a woman right now that's fantastic
i remember the one that you did with uh
with john uh walsh because we had john
walsh on the show as well and but you
guys did the uh barbie girl by aqua that
got super trolled oh did it that was bad
that was what what what for what was the
main thing that got you oh my god i
didn't like the song or what hold on
let's find one let's find some comments
the uh but yeah so basically the video
is they did a parody of it was uh i'm a
pfizer girl
right
so john and her in the car and they're
singing you know which i don't know how
anyone would get offended but of course
it's you know i guess it's about the
vaccine so someone's gonna be like
that's the other thing that i think is
happening is the reason why
uh they're doing parody of themselves is
because they actually don't understand
like comedy like they don't they don't
truly get that's the one line that i see
all the time is the left can't meme i
get that comment a bunch of on your
video on the videos they'll be like it's
not a meme yeah they're like the left
can't meme or whatever it is and i'm
like this isn't a meme this is a sketch
i'm talking about something i'm making
fun of it but it's not a meme oh here's
here's one of the comments this not only
makes me want to avoid getting the
vaccine i would actually now like it if
someone could inject coven 19 directly
into my frontal lobe so that i might
forget i ever saw this
i'm actually i'm not opposed to that to
be quite yeah go right ahead see you
later i mean on twitter
oh wow i think my dad on twitter it was
like nearly 600 000 views i think please
arrest these two people
wow i you know i'm so disturbed the end
times are here cringe i think the end
times were here before all of this but
sure i'll i'll you know i have i'll [ __ ]
post i'll you know whatever on people
and you know especially people who are
like of power and you know i'm not sure
i'm not going to punch down always punch
up always right
um
so i do my fair take however on the
trolling side yeah it's insane like to
say that stuff about someone you don't
know because it takes away there's like
a total lack of empathy to then say like
well what would that person do if the
reverse happened right and i could tell
you exactly what would happen
they would then say don't attack me
don't be mean don't come after me i'm
the victim
after they had just attacked you or
someone else for that exact thing right
so i think you know you see all the time
it's like you see conservatives who are
like oh no i'm the victim don't cancel
me it's like you were just attack you
were it's like yeah it's like this
person was literally beating someone up
in the street and then they were getting
arrested like well i'm the victim i they
made me do it and it's like that's a
lack of self-awareness
let me tell you i i grew up in white
america i'm still in white america and
these people are so so so
so wanting to be oppressed it is
absolutely disgusting it's like why are
why are you looking for reasons to act
like you you are being oppressed and you
know what oppression is this this
nonsense you've seen the robert
f kennedy jr where he's talking last
weekend about how the holocaust i'm like
will you people quit being so gross will
you stop you don't
and and then when they did they compare
um the vaccine you know passport or
whatever where you have to have vaccine
card to get a restaurant the segregation
and [ __ ] i'm like oh my god you you are
choosing not to have a vaccine card
black people in the south during
segregation did not it couldn't just
take off the color of their skin you
morons like how in the world can't you
see this and it is really disgusting and
gross but it goes back to they don't
really like socially something has been
disconnected here because
they don't understand the satire they
don't understand the parody and
obviously they don't understand little
connections like
you have to
be vaccinated to go in a restaurant and
that being a requirement not a mandate
but a requirement right and then you
choosing not to do that is not
segregation it is i think it's a total
lag
yeah well like you said they have a
choice right i think it's a total total
lack of attention right so for i think
for a period of time
they may have been given attention they
were the focus and then oh god forbid we
focus on the people that don't have a
voice or don't have uh the ability to to
speak uh and represent themselves
because this other group was pushing
them down and now they have an
opportunity to tell you like hey listen
we have been ignored and we want
attention brought to this and you know
we should these rights should be given
to
this group and that group so that
everyone is equal and then they're like
whoa guys guys you know cameras back on
us okay you know like that's what it is
it's very much like the pick me kind of
mentality and vibe as soon as the focus
shifts like we've racked focus to a
group in the background on a movie and
then they're like hey and they're like
in the screen to be like hey look no no
i'm foreground come back at me and
you're like calm down so so let me ask
you missy because i live in missouri
which they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything here like we haven't g they
haven't given a [ __ ] about coronavirus
since since like the summer of 2020 here
and gable is out in los angeles and we
talk a little bit about that but you're
in new york correct yeah so tell us
about what because everyone that's one
thing they're like oh new york's a hell
hole and it's like a
you can't do anything there and tell us
about what it actually is like there i
mean if you're vaccinated you could do
whatever you want
like go to a restaurant go to a museum
like normal type [ __ ] right yeah like
literally i mean everything's a risk
still right and right cases luckily are
going down here but
no i don't worry about that because i'm
vaccinated and boosted so i that's not
even like on my radar but if you're
wanting to see a broadway show
sorry bud you can go see one you can go
see once but i also i'm not going to say
that a certain group isn't um
uh
educated or at least appreciates arts in
certain way but if you're if you're
we're already part of these groups who
were going or rather were not going to
broadway and you're not getting back set
in i doubt they're gonna then show up be
like i want my hamilton you know it's
like
you probably weren't gonna show up
anyway did you guys see today that
they're going to boycott walmart then
quebec and quebec i guess walmart for
what labor issues probably no no no
absolutely not no no no it cannot be for
the actual
jesus christ gabe you actually you're
trying to talk about real social issues
here but they're going to boycott
walmart people
rednecks toothless rednecks in in
in our country are going to boycott
walmart because in quebec they
apparently have to have a mask mandate
so walmart had a sign and someone posted
this sign on social media basically
basically said anyone 13 and up has to
have a vaccine and a mask i guess it's
just like they're instituting it right
now because the virus is running through
their um uh their territory right now so
walmart has done this so the entirety of
maga in our country is like no walmart
i'm like really
walmart yeah
let's go through the list and uh let's
figure it out no target no pepsi no
coca-cola no delta no home depot i mean
i mean missy you said you said broadway
shows it would be really easy for manga
to to boycott broadsh broadway yeah and
then they'll be like how many dings in
that revenue stream for them would that
be zero
zero it's like for rent i'm going to
give up something they hate so they
don't really care right right i'm going
to give up giving up things yeah that's
what i always did yeah i really i really
appreciate you joining us so here's what
i want you to do i want you to tell us
where you find all your content because
i know you're on all the social media
channels but tell us tell us how to find
you where to find you tell the audience
because they want to go see these new
videos that are going to be released
yes things are happening i'm really
excited i'm feeling motivated i'm
excited for my video with gabe um you
can find me on instagram or tick tock at
missy modell
i'm working on some fun things are you
on the tweety tweets and are you on the
tweet no come on come on come on you got
i'm gonna drag you over there drag me
there grab me that's my plan the water's
nice over there i'm gonna i'm gonna put
yeah right
that's kind of it's still it's
warm it's great yeah it's literally
it's that pool in the back that you're
like uh we got a pool but like no one's
cleaned it and there's like pine needles
in it
yeah and everyone's peed in it it's you
know it's it's it's free of covert
because everyone's peed in it right
no i i like twitter because when i was
on tick tock i i felt it difficult
because you just post a video and you're
just like waiting right like twitter you
can like hey interrupt this right yeah
you can try to you can try to curate the
the content a little better and and i
like the sh i like this [ __ ] talk let's
do all right i'm gonna go with you then
the next time i get sad and you can just
you just come to me i'll take care i'll
take care of the trolls for you my mom's
always like let me get in your head for
a day i i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
she's like she said i'm too nice so
she's like who cares right that's my
attitude [ __ ] them [ __ ] i don't you
know you just you got to give them
crickets and really honestly you got to
look at it like gabe was saying earlier
like oh they're boosting the algorithm
you know all these all these thousands
and thousands of troll comments now i
will say um because earlier you guys
were talking about muting i i do like to
mute i don't like to block as much some
people say you must block for certain
things but there are there are those
those instances where they're giving uh
death threats and stuff um it does it
does cross the line so you know they end
up they end up reported to my uh my
local law enforcement oh okay well yeah
when they get a phone call from you know
some
some person it's like what the [ __ ] is
this
[Laughter]
i i can't believe that in this day and
age but maybe we should believe it that
uh the internet is such a vile swamp but
yet there's this place there is this
place over on tick tock it's a page that
someone has missy modell if you want to
go and you wanna and you wanna see and
you wanna laugh and you wanna smile and
you wanna hear great songs and great
parodies go over there go to her tic-tac
page or instagram but go to the tiki
talks and and follow me and make sure
that you check out these videos missy
thank you for joining us come back any
time i'm going to do this it's so fun
you're just amazing absolutely well
thank you thank you very much you don't
have to flatter out but i i i will i
will say i will say make sure when when
we get these videos i'll make sure to
play them on the show and i'll tag you
on twitter is what i'll do
keep an eye on keep an eye on your
twitter account thank you very much
oh thank you well i i went today to do
my missy research and i think i followed
all the good i'm going to go find
your youtube channel i ain't following
you wow all right i'm going to go i went
over there to make sure you had a
youtube channel so thank you missy for
joining us stick around we'll be right
back after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
hello and welcome to a dramatic reading
of text messages sent to mark meadows on
january 6th can he make a statement
ask people to leave the capitol
fox news host sean hannity please get
him on tv
destroying everything you have
accomplished
fox news host brian kilmeade mark the
president needs to tell people in the
capitol to go home
this is hurting all of us he is
destroying his legacy
fox news host laura ingram he's got to
condemn this [ __ ] asap
the capital police tweet is not enough
we need an oval office address
he has to lead now
it has gone too far and gotten out of
hand
donald trump jr and this has been a
dramatic reading of text messages sent
to mark meadows on january 6th
[Music]
[ __ ] em
[ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us to the
interview an interview it was dave that
is such a
such a great interview with with missy
and i had a lot of fun doing that one
yeah it was great oh absolutely
absolutely yeah i have her back anytime
anytime you would like to come back
very talented oh absolutely and everyone
go go follow missy because um i hear i
hear tale that there's going to be a
couple videos dropping is that is that
the truth that is true yeah i just gotta
wrap them up and uh okay put it on the
interwebs on the on on the interwebs the
webbing webs of the internet so some
people were saying that we didn't do the
[ __ ] list roundup today uh we we did not
get a lot of time but i do i do want to
go um real quick for the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends for everyone out
there uh desiring to be on the tweety
tweets and trendy trends let's actually
refresh here and see what is trending um
so you can go check that out uh
because i think uh a restaurant now was
trending earlier yeah that was one of
the big things and i think merrick
garland's also uh trending and the
reason why is because they want people
uh want merrick garland to go arrest uh
donald trump for his rally and the
things he said nazis is trending uh i
always love when nazis are turning i
have a ton of
antifa uh material that i can pose for
nazis
but that's it i i think it's trending
because that the undercover and for uh
the undercover agent from the fbi
okay so what what's going on there do
you know the story real quick
i haven't read the full story but
basically there's a guy that
works for the fbi and he's spent the
last 25 years infiltrating nazis the
clan and biker gangs is this where he's
saying hey the wild [ __ ] is coming if we
don't pay attention is that kind of the
the uh
yeah again like i haven't finished it
yet but i mean like i would imagine that
you know he's like
these people are
you know integrated within many facets
of our society
we already know that they're you know
within the police force and other places
so right i mean even the military i mean
you know
we've seen that with all these uh former
military
uh even people that were on the national
guard that right had to be removed from
kind of
the
their position at the capitol right so
here's number 20 garland and then it's
trending with the rest trump now uh
after the speech given by donald trump a
texas rally on saturday the nazi rally
um some are urging attorney general
merrick garland to pursue criminal
charges which i i think that's why he's
standing on stage saying what he's
saying he's saying hey
hey um i'm gonna pardon all the
criminals make sure elect me so i can
pardon myself kind of thing even maybe
right i'm of course number one i don't
know i also think that a lot of these
people have uh
uh
just hubris like
intense amounts of hubris rather like
you know matt gates is another [ __ ]
example of someone who's like
probably gonna keep running for
re-election while he's literally being
raided by the fbi so you know these
people think that they're invincible and
they are
uh
immune to any sort of so he can just say
whatever the [ __ ] he wants is what
you're yeah and i think here too like i
don't know if trump is dumb uh cocky
whatever you want to call it but like
you know he's on stage saying these
things he sends a press release sends
says saying these things
and i don't know if it's for a lack of
like
public
movement on trump and people around him
or or what but you know
i think that's why people were like yo
garland uh we're gonna get something
right right [ __ ] give us a bone here
like this dude is literally saying this
quiet part out loud like let's act on
something well you know i think some of
this too is he's a little afraid about
what is in the documents that the
january 6th select committee has now too
you know yeah i mean like every chance
he's had to try to block it has been
denied right right they well they
finally got their hands on it so number
24 trending is black history month we
know february's black history month
which black history is american history
and american history is black history so
um but um we're moving into february and
i'm sure there's going to be plenty of
really really hot takes on that that
we'll be able to discuss i'm sure i'm
sure there'll be people end up in the
bonehead of the week over black history
month i'm sure yeah i wouldn't be
surprised if christian walker made
himself on there i did
or candace owens right i mean last year
i have a video that i did with him or
like not with him
yeah i've got a video where he talks
about he's like enough with the black
history month we need white history
month i was like oh boy jesus
christ but [ __ ] bonehead so yeah i'm
sure i'm sure him and candace will end
up on the bone of the week newsome is
trending here i'm not sure why some
criticized california governor new
zealand because he went to a basketball
game yeah and i will admit i will agree
with this he basically went to a you
know a stadium for a game
and
was not wearing a mask now obviously
he's vaccinating he's boosted but at the
same time it's like
right you
know all the rules that you're setting
right uh let's see is it what's in the
for you
uh rogan uh joe rogan you guys seen uh
spotify is now placating um to some of
the artists where they're saying they're
gonna put advisories i don't know if
this is going again i i don't i don't
this is oh i'm sorry for getting caught
that's all this is it's well they're not
going to they're not going to give up
that hundred million dollars no not at
all i mean like it doesn't matter what
artist and i keep i keep telling people
this like it doesn't matter what artist
and how many they're not they're
the amount of money that they're making
to pay joe rogan a hundred million
dollars is a lot of [ __ ] money and
and it's sad to say but but the grift is
very profitable in this country the
misinformation grift is very profitable
why do you think rogan's doing it and
why do you think spotify is like yeah
we're just gonna you know we're just
gonna we're gonna placate this stuff now
it does seem like they're gonna give
some sort of uh um advisory that he is
misinformation which will really [ __ ]
piss him off because then it's
cancelling the white dude you know the
white dude's getting ready
so again like this only happened because
people sp you know again there are
let's keep in mind there are a lot of
really [ __ ] crazy issues that are
happening in the world especially in
america that we probably should focus
more attention on you know yes the
spotify thing is is important in the
sense that we have misinformation or
disinformation being spread through a
very influential person uh but let's not
forget that spotify here is acting in
their own best interest right right see
well yeah i mean they're apparently
four billion
you know so this is just an act of like
oh [ __ ] uh okay i guess people really
were serious and then from there
he makes a statement that says like
we're now going to put disclaimers on it
now you know whether
you don't do anything or not let's hope
let's hope that the disclaimer pisses
off rogan enough to walk away from the
contract
yeah i mean i guess that's what that's
the best you could ask for maybe that's
what spotify is doing here is trying to
i don't know where else he would go well
i mean he could just go back on his own
platform and yeah that's true you know i
mean he had his own platform before
beforehand and his audience followed him
but i wouldn't be surprised if chick
gets flagged on youtube i mean there's
been multiple people that have been
removed
his channel and they permanently
suspended it because he tried to finagle
his way into another channel or some
[ __ ] right something so he's gone which
i mean you know i i'm not opposed to
spotify telling rogan to go [ __ ] himself
but what i am saying is if you want to
show spotify if you really want to show
them uh what's what is go support the
content that doesn't spread
misinformation and i mean
subscribe spread it around tell your
friends to listen to it because
if if you get all the the
actual people who are trying to get the
real information out to the
pro-democracy information um in the
hands of people so they can make this
real decisions on real information
if if spotify is not a thing and all
those people don't have a platform that
platform can exist for that type of
material as well so right um
it kind of goes both ways but you know i
i i i don't ever want to disparage
someone for their right to you know
boycott or or whatever you know
undownload spotify that's fine whatever
you want to do it's the same thing when
i post trump's statement that is very
relevant in the time where we're trying
to stop a fascist state and you say
oh stop posting it like look it's my
[ __ ] account i can post whatever i
want yeah i'm posting something that's
very relevant you know the great thing
about the internet is you can close it
block it mute it or scroll past it
whatever yeah well i think we had a
great show today it was [ __ ]
fantastic we had rachel bitkoffer on uh
explaining trump's uh weekend i mean it
was a whole [ __ ] weekend of just nazi
craziness uh then we had we had donald
trump on himself it might be crazy it
might be john john walsh i don't know i
don't know
follow go follow john
it's at it's john walsh on twitter and
all the other you know social medias if
you're out there go go follow him there
because it possibly was him and
hopefully if it was john playing trump
maybe we can get him play a few more of
his other characters here on the show
and let us know yeah i'll do the youtube
thing go down in the comments and let us
know uh you know what other characters
you want john to come on and go tell
john that too uh so support john and
then of course the interview with missy
was uh fantastic of course she kicked my
ass and uh
but you know
i i generally get my ass kicked in
trivia so yeah yeah it is what it is it
is what it is so that's that's that's
what we got and i i apologize that we
didn't have a lot of time to surf the
tweety tweets and the trinity jordans i
promise the shitless roundup will be
back tomorrow full force
full for force
first hour i think i think i may have
some um some other people that are
coming on and we have some great guests
coming up like we did some recordings
over the last week that are going to be
just [ __ ] huge so everyone's going to
want to pay attention to that we have
some great interviews going to come out
um so you know i i mean guess until
tomorrow at noon eastern 11 central [ __ ]
them what do you guys welcome all right
we'll see we'll see you tomorrow
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking